Le spui că eu filmez
și le faci așa dinainte. Ia uite,
Marius.
Vă salut, dragi pescari. Suntem din nou
pe apă și de data asta suntem pe mal, nu
în barcă așa cum v am obișnuit. Sunt la
Maliuc. O să fac o partidă de pescuit de
patru zile, iar în această partidă vreau
să filmez fiecare pas pe care eu îl fac
atunci când pescuiesc de pe mal și mai
ales pe brațul Sulina, pentru că brațul
Sulina este un braț greu de pescuit, mai
ales zona unde a fost făcută artificial,
unde este digul de piatră și o să explic
în tot clipul acesta cum trebuie abordat
praguri de piatră, cum trebuie să nădim,
cu ce fire să pescuim, riguri. O să
încerc să vă dau toate detaliile
necesare ca să puteți să faceți o
partidă reușită pe sulina.
Tot în clipul acesta vreau să
vă povestesc un pic despre pescuitul pe
sălbatic pentru că am văzut în ultima
perioadă mulți clienți de fapt am mulți
clienți care mă sună și mă întreabă:
"Vreau și eu o nadă pentru pescuit, o
nadă bună, mă duc acolo și vreau să
prind pește, că am pescuit cu nu știu ce
nadă și nu am prins pește."
Ei bine, dragilor,
aici nu este vorba de nadă, este vorba
de priceperea pescarului, este vorba de
alegerea locului, este vorba de
strategia pe care o abordăm atunci când
mergem la o partidă de pescuit.
Sunt cazuri în care nu se prinde pește
și motivele sunt destul de clare,
motivele sunt bine știute de către
pescarii care au studiat lucrul acesta,
dar pescarii care sunt poate la început
sau poate care nu au studiat sau poate
care nu au avut informațiile acestea
merg pe apă, pescuiesc și spun că nada
nu e bună sau că na, balta n are pește.
În condițiile noastre Dunărea nu are
pește.
O să încerc să explic pe parcurs. O să
am așa o bucată întreagă în care o să
vreau să discutăm despre acest lucru. Ce
vreau să vă zic este că o partidă de
pescuit este reușită dacă avem o
strategie bine pusă la punct și dacă
reușim în cu în pe parcursul partidei să
ne adaptăm la condițiile în care ne
aflăm. O să vorbim despre
cotele apelor, o să vorbim despre
presiune atmosferică, o să vorbim despre
riguri, o să vorbim despre înaintași.
Chiar o să fac un test partida asta cu
înaintași de 0,90
un fir destinat pescuitului la somn, un
noufilament. O să vreau să pescuiesc cu
el. Să vedem dacă reușim să pescuim pe
pragul de
de la pe pragul de de fapt pe adâncime
mai mare. Haideți să vă explic un pic ca
să ca să înțelegeți. Poate că mulți
dintre voi care vă vă uitați acum
cunoașteți pescuitul pe sulina,
cunoașteți brațul sulina și știți cum
sunt pragurile, dar vreau să explic și
pentru cei care nu știu. Sulina este un
braț făcut artificial și este făcut din
piatră. O să O să filmez un pic să
vedeți cum arată malul și trebuie să vă
gândiți că la fel arată și pe sub apă.
Da? Și o să încerc eu să vă explic așa
un pic. Deci unde sunt eu? Aici este
malul. Ok. După care vine un prag care
se duce până în apă la o adâncime de 3
m, 3,5 m, 2,5 m în funcție de cota apei.
Da? Deci aici se termină pragul. După
care urmează un platou de 7 m, 5 m, 6 m,
10 m, 15 m, în funcție de zona în care
pescuiți. Da? După care coboară din nou
un alt prag care se duce la aproximativ
12 m adâncime în unele zone 10 m, 11 m,
12 m, 13 m și în funcție de cota apelor.
Da? Deci așa arată malul pe sulina,
majoritatea părților pe sulina cam așa.
Cam așa arată. Ok. Bun. Noi ce o să
facem? De fapt, hai să începem cu
problema cea mai mare pe sulină.
Problema cea mai mare bate vântul și
sper că sper că se aude se aude bine la
varieră.
Cea mai mare problemă pe solina este
pescuitul la adâncime atunci când
pescuim de pe mal. Da, dacă noi suntem
aici, am zis că avem un prag care ne
duce până la adâncime de 3 m, după care
avem o o întinsură unde apa are 3 m și
după care iar avem o adâncitură, avem un
prag care se duce până la 12 m. În
condițiile de vară cel mai des găsim
peștele la adâncime mare. Da? Adică aici
la baza pragului la 12 m. Dar noi cum
pescuim de pe mal nu avem cum să scoatem
peștele de acolo. Lansăm, să zicem, se
duce, se duce plumbul în mal, se duce
plumbul în prag, dar atunci când noi
vrem să scoatem peștele, când avem
trăsătură, nu reușim pentru că se agață
în pietrele pe care le ați văzut mai
devreme. Da. Și se taie firul. Efectiv
se taie firul. Cele mai bune rezultate
le am avut pe eu încerc să vă arăt mereu
ca să aveți să vă faceți o imagine, să
vă faceți o imagine, să vă dați seama
cum arată pragul. Eu am pescuit cel mai
des pe pragul pe întinsura de 3 m, pe
adâncimea de 3 m și aici am avut cele
mai bune rezultate. Dar am avut cele mai
bune rezultate de ce? Pentru că de aici
am putut să scot peștii. Eu am încercat
să pescuiesc și pe adâncime de 12 m de
pe mal. Am avut trăsături, dar nu am nu
am reușit să scot peștii pentru că s a
tăiat firul. De fapt, s a tăiat firul.
cele mai multe cele mai multe de fapt în
toate cazurile s a tăiat firul și atunci
noi am avut rezultate pe pragul de pe
întinsura unde apa are 3 m. Asta vom
face și în partida asta. Sunt împreună
cu prietenii mei. Suntem în jur de fapt
suntem opt pescari. Toți au câte patru
lansete. Suntem întinși pe un mal întreg
la Maliuc. Și ce o să facem noi în
partida asta?
O să ne vin cu bile. Este, suntem în
luna august, la jumătatea lunii, nu spre
sfârșitul lunii august. Suntem cred că
în 20 și Ia să vedem. În 26. Deci suntem
în data de 26. Temperatura apei este
destul de este destul de mare. A fost
caniculă. Au fost câteva zile de frig. O
să discutăm și despre aspectul ăsta, dar
zic așa în mod general. Da.
Apa este apa este încă caldă și nădind
cu bile. Facem o nădire destul de masivă
cu bile pe pragul de 3 m, pe înisura de
3 m. Da, nădim un pic în amonte. Bilele
vin unde noi nădim.
Asta este. Ăsta este lucrul. Așa o să
nădim. Da. Iar
ca și pescuit, eu voi pescui cu două
lansete pe momitoare și două lansete pe
plumb, pe plumb simplu, plumb pierdut
sau plumb in line cu bilă la cârlig.
Pe momitoare să La momitoare o să
pescuiesc cu pelete de 15 mm solubile și
la pe celelalte două lansete o să
pescuiesc cu bile simple, solubile. În
prima parte o să încep cu bile solubile,
după care o să încep să pescuiesc cu
Delta Secret, care sunt biletari, iar pe
noapte, clar o să toate patru o să fie
pe Delta Secret, pe biletari. O să o să
las lansetele în apă și pe noapte.
Și sper eu pe noapte să intre ceva mai
mare. Bun, haideți să revenim un pic la
pragul acesta de pe sulina. Eu
am pescuit de câteva ori de pe mal pe
sulină și în unele partide am observat
că Deci cum din nou vă arăt pragul, aici
este, aici este întinsura unde apă are 3
m și de aici începe coborârea. Da, de
multe ori eu am avut rezultate mai bune
fix pe buza coborârii sau poate chiar un
pic un pic cu Deci gândiți vă că aici
apare 3 m și de aici începe să scadă.
Da, așa așa arată pragul. Ă, am încercat
să pescuiesc undeva pe buza pragului și
cumva un pic jos de prag. Da, foarte
puțin, nu știu, să zic 1 m în fața
pragului ca să cadă un pic sub prag unde
începe să coboare. Am avut rezultate mai
bune, dar ce înseamnă rezultate mai
bune? Pești un pic mai mari. Dacă pe
pragul de 3 m prindeam ciortani la 1,
dou pe buza respectivă sau mai jos de
buza pragului prindeam la 3 k 4 kg. Asta
o să încerc și în partida asta și testul
pe care o să l fac acum o să fie cu un
fir de somn de 0
de monofilament și o să încerc să pun în
jur de 7 m pe ca și ca și înaintaș și o
să încerc să pescuiesc și pe buza
pragului și o să încerc să mă duc și mai
jos și mai jos. Câte puțin, câte puțin.
Ok.
C și rig o să folosesc cârlige de
șase atunci când pescuiesc cu bile,
cârlige de opt atunci când pescuiesc cu
pelete solubile. Dar aici mare grijă și
vreau să vreau să fiți un pic atenți
pentru că
mărimea cârligor diferă de la un
producător la altul. Dacă eu î spun să
folosiți cârlige de șase, s ar putea la
un producător să găsiți cârlige de L6 să
fie mai mari decât restul
producătorilor. Și mi s a întâmplat
chestia asta des.
Așa că nu mă mai iau neapărat după
numărul cârligelor, ci efectiv mă uit la
ele și îmi dau seama îmi dau seama după
mărimea momelii pe care vreau să
folosesc, ce fel de ce fel de cârlig să
folosesc. Dar o să vă arăt o să v o să
vă explic lucrul ăsta în momentul în
care o să o să vă arăt cum se face un
rig. O să pescuiesc rigurile. O să le
fac cu o fir cămășuit. Trece o barcă.
Sper că mă auziți.
Rigurile o să le fac cu fir cămășuit. Am
observat în ultimele partide că dacă am
folosit firul cămășuit nu mi s a mai
rupt firul din rig. Am avut înainte am
avut multe multe rupturi de la rig.
Scoteam untura, scoteam plumbul și
rigul, rigul era rupt. Firul textilul
era firul textil era rupt. Iar acum, în
ultimele partide, am folosit fir
cămășuit și nu mi s a mai rupt de la
rig. Ba chiar am observat pe firul
cămășuit că era destul de zdrelit așa.
Era destul de zdrențuros pentru că se
lovea în pietre. Ok, un alt lucru pe
care o să l fac o să pescuiesc cu
plumbierdut. De ce cu plumb pierdut?
Pentru că avem sistemele este sistemul
de la plumb pierdut. O să vi l arăt
oricum când fac montura. este sistemul
de la plimb plumb pierdut care ajută în
momentul în care plumbul s a agățat într
o piatră să să rămână plumbul acolo.
Efectiv plumbul se pierde, dar recuperez
montura, recuperez cârligul și asta la
ce ne ajută? Ne ajută în momentul în
care avem un drill pentru că peștele
vine, începe, îți ia fir. Asta dacă
folosim dacă folosim și opritor la
sistemul de plumb pierdut.
Dacă nu folosim, dacă nu folosim, poate
să ia fir. Dacă folosim, trebuie să
ridice, trebuie să ridice momitorul, să
ridice plumbul de pe substrat. Dacă
plumbul este blocat în chetre, el trage,
trage un pic, o să vezi semnalizare,
după care plumbul rămâne acolo și este
posibil să staie firul pentru că el este
blocat efectiv acolo și tu când tragi îl
simți că este blocat, tragi, tragi,
tragi și la un moment dat se rupe firul.
Dar dacă avem plumb pierdut, în momentul
în care noi tragem, datorită sistemului
de la plumbier, plumbul rămâne acolo, se
eliberează firul împreună cu acel sistem
și putem să avem drilul și putem să
scoatem putem să scoatem mai ușor
peștii. Pescuitul pe sulina este un
pescuit dificil și este un pescuit
dificil datorită acestui datorită
acestui lucru pentru că avem pragul
acesta de piatră.
Pe chilia și pe Sfântul Gheorghe este
mult mai ușor de de pescuit chiar în
praguri pentru că nu se taie firul.
Chiar hai să zicem se taie și acolo
firul sau se
se blochează în prag, dar
de cele mai multe ori reușești să l
scoți. Mă uit acuma la prietenii mei că
ei au avut au avut o trăsătură.
Am avut o trăsătură și
>> nu știu dacă nu știu dacă reușește să l
scoată pentru că sunt niște prieteni din
Republica Moldova care au venit cu noi,
au fost și anul trecut, le a plăcut
foarte mult și au zis că vor să vină și
anul ăsta. Au venit și ei n au o
experiență prea mare pe Dunăre. Ei
pescuiesc acol acolo pe bălț. Iar acum
când au lansat când a lansat prima dată
Victor, a lansat pe pragul acela de vă
explicam eu aici la adâncime la 12 m și
nu cred că o să reușească să l scoată să
scoată de acolo chiar dacă a avut
trăsătură, dar trăsătura a fost violentă
pentru că i a luat i luat lăsetat de pe
roadpot. Da, deci a venit prima
trăsătură la viitor. Bun, haideți să vă
mai spun un pic despre pescuitul pe ape
sălbatice. Am văzut așa o supărare o
supărare în rândul clienților
ai mei și al altor firme și să zic am
văzut în online supărare pe pe clienți
sau pe pescari că nu se prinde pește pe
sălbatic.
Și vreau să vă zic că cumva și noi
suntem vinovați brandurile care producem
care producem nade și mumeli pentru că
de cele mai multe ori postăm partidele
în care prindem pește.
Și asta lasă o imagine falsă clientului
pentru că el crede că dacă ai luat o
momeală pe care tu ai văzut o că s a
prins pește la ea, tu ai impresia că va
trebui să prinzi pește, la fel cum a
prins pescarul care ți a postat sau
brandul care ți a postat. Dar pescarii
nu iau un calcul foarte multe aspecte.
Da. Și asta pentru că nu, probabil nu s
au lovit de ele, probabil nu le a
explicat nimeni, probabil nu au învățat,
probabil n au experiența necesară ca să
și dea seama. Și o să vreau să vă dau un
exemplu foarte foarte simplu și să
vorbim despre temperatura apei și despre
presiunea atmosferică.
Gândiți vă și despre cota apei. Gândiți
vă în felul următor. Un pescar a fost la
pescuit pe cotă în creștere sau o cotă
stabilă și a pescuit, să zicem, pesulina
pe pragul de 3 m. Ok?
Cota fiind fiind destul de măricică,
deci nu o cotă scăzută. Da. Asta ce
înseamnă? Că peștele este în poate să
fie în zona de 3 m. Da, dar dacă cota
apei este în scădere, peștele ca și
comportament, el când simte o scădere,
mai ales o scădere bruscă, se va duce la
apa adâncă pentru că el vrea să
supraviețuiască, nu vrea să rămână în
băltoace, nu vrea să fie izolat undeva
și atunci se duce unde apa este cea mai
adâncă. Ok. Și dacă acest pescar a fost
la o partidă de pescuit, hai să zicem
invers, dacă a fost la o partidă de
pescuit în care condițiile atmosferice
cu temperatura apei, cota, presiunea nu
erau ok, nu a prins pește și să zicem că
a pescuit cu o nadă sau o momeală pe
care a văzut o el pe internet că că o
promovează anumiți pescari. Da. Și
pescarul ce alege să zică„Nu, domnule,
am pescuit cu na de aia nu am prins
niciun pește. Ok? Care este complet
fals. De ce? pentru că condițiile nu au
fost favorabile. Nu au fost favorabile
pentru el și atunci nu a prins pește.
Același pescar vine și cumpără nadă sau
momele de la mine. Se duce pe o cotă ok,
pe o temperatură a apei ok, pe presiune
ok. Prinde pește, zice: "Mamă, ce nadă
bună ai, ce nu știu ce, ce nu știu ce."
Și am am întâlnit lucrul ăsta. Eu le
spun pescarilor: "Domnule, nu este doar
de la nadă ai avut noroc. Ai dat într o
zonă. Pentru că pot să mi dau seama de
pescarii care țin cont de anumite
aspecte ăă cum am zis temperatură
ăă
iertați mă, dar sunt și un pic distras
pentru că prietenii mei sunt în fața mea
și tot ba el lansează, ba mă uitam la
Victor să văd dacă a scos peștele. Nu,
nu n a reușit să l scoată.
Bun, revenim. Deci pescarii nu țin cont
de multe aspecte și atunci
au partide în care prind pește și acolo
este pur noroc și au partide în care nu
prind pește și acolo este pur ghinion
pentru că și au ales o perioadă în care
să meargă la pescuit în care condițiile
nu sunt favorabile pentru ele. În acest
clip o să încerc să abordez aceste
subiecte mai pe larg.
Sper să reușesc să explic bine, chiar
dacă adică sper să nu vă supărați dacă
mă repet în anumite situații, pentru că
vreau să înțelegeți că pescuitul nu este
doar despre nade și mumeli, ci pescuitul
este despre o strategie bine pusă la
punct și un bagaj mare de cunoștințe
care vă ajută să prindeți pește. În alte
clipuri am spus că eu pe sălbatic prind
pește aproape de fiecare dată și așa
este. Mi s a întâmplat foarte foarte
rar. Mi s a întâmplat să nu prind pește
pe sălbatic. Ok, dar prind pentru că am
foarte multe informații descoperite de
mine, descoperite de la alți pescari,
învățate de la alți pescari, pe care eu
le aplic în momentul în care merg la o
partidă de pescuit. Cum sunt acum în
momentul de față, o să zic ce se
întâmplă în momentul de față, ca să
înțelegeți un pic. Coda este în scădere.
Sunt un pic, să zic așa, n aș zice
neapărat dezamăgit, dar sunt am un pic o
frică că nu vom reuși să prindem pește
pentru că cota este destul de mult în
scădere. Ok? Asta ce înseamnă? Că
peștele va căuta să stea la adâncime?
Cel puțin peștii mari vor căuta să stea
la adâncime, adică la pragul acela pe
care eu v am spus că nu putem să l
pescuim, cel puțin de pe mal. Ok?
Pe lângă acest lucru, am
astăzi în mașină când veneam, am stat să
mi fac așa un
o mic o strategie să mă gândesc ce se
întâmplă cu peștele acum și uitându mă
în bord la mașină am văzut că sunt 12°
afară și mi am adus aminte că deja de
patru zile noaptea a fost frig și a
bătut vântul și ba chiar a fost și o
furtună pe deltă ceva. Asta ce înseamnă?
Că
apa de la suprafață s a răcit. Am legat
și cu concediul în care eu am fost la
mare a săptămâna trecută m am întors, de
fapt duminică acum m am întors de la
mare și vineri a fost o furtună, a fost
frig noaptea, iar ziua când ne am dus să
intrăm în apă, a doua zi, sâmbătă când
ne am dus să intrăm în apă, apa era
foarte rece. Ok.
Cel puțin pentru noi. O simțeam la
picioare foarte rece până când ne
obișnuiam față de atunci când când am
ajuns la mare în care apa era caldă și
puteai să intri în ea fără probleme.
Bun, am luat și în legal lucrurile astea
și am zis în felul următor am avut o
perioadă de caniculă în care temperatura
apei a fost destul de ridicată. Peștii
au stat la adâncime pentru că
temperatura apei era ridicată și apa se
nu se oxigenează atunci când este cald
și nu sunt valuri și peștele stă la
adâncime la temperatură mai scăzută sau
unde temperatura este mai constantă
decât la suprafață.
În mașină când mă gândeam și am legat
toate lucrurile astea zic: „Dar stai un
pic că noi s ar putea să avem niște
șanse." De ce? Având în vedere că apa a
fost mult timp foarte caldă și
neoxigenată,
acum pentru că a venit o scădere de
temperatură,
a răcit apa de la suprafață. Da.
Valurile au oxigenat apa de la suprafață
și atunci este posibil
bine vântul și mi ia umbrela. Și atunci
este posibil ca peștele să stea între
ape. Când peștele stă între ape, el nu
neapărat că stă între ape pe mijlocul
apei. El s ar putea să stea între ape,
poate să stea la adâncime de 2 m, poate
să stea la adâncime de 1 m, poate să
stea la adâncime de 3 m. Asta înseamnă
că el ar putea să stea în apropiele în
apropierea malurilor, să urce în
apropierea malurilor pentru că
la apă de 3 m, de 2 m, pentru că apa
este oxigenată. Da. pentru că a fost au
fost valuri, au fost vânt și s a
oxigenat apa și apa s a răcit un pic la
suprafață, dar nu s a răcit atât de mult
încât să l sperie. Ok, deci asta mi a
dat un pic de speranțe în partida asta
și am zis: "Ok, s ar putea să avem o
partidă cât de cât reușită de pe mal."
Încerc să vă explic lucrurile astea ca
să vă dați seama că în momentul în care
nu prindeți pește pe o locație care ați
mai prins pește sau pe locație unde alți
prieteni de ai voștri au fost și au
prins pește și v au recomandat să vă
duceți acolo, vreau să vă gândiți că
lucrurile s au schimbat. Da, temperatura
este schimbată, presiunea atmosferică
este schimbată, cota e schimbată.
Nu mai este aceeași situație în care
altcineva a prins pește sau voi ați
prins pește. Și ca noi să prindem pește
de cele mai multe ori trebuie să se
alinieze toate astrele. Așa zice Mihai
Mane, dacă vrea bunuțul să alinieze
toate astrele, reușim să scoatem și noi
un pește mare să nu intre niciodată, să
nu intre în prag, să nu știu ce, să nu
știu ce, să nu știu ce. Da, deci trebuie
să aliniem toate, să se alinieze toate
astrele și eu o să încerc să vă ajut să
vă dau cât mai multe informații despre
lucrurile pe care eu le fac sau de care
eu țin cont atunci când merg la pescuit
și poate cine știe o să ajute pe câțiva
dintre voi. Cam atât. Cam atât pentru
această introducere, deși consider că
este deja prea lungă. O să încerc deja
mi am montat roadpod ul. O să încep să
mi fac lansetele. În timp ce î fac
lansetele și o să pun înaintașul de care
vă vorbeam, o să o să și filmez să vă
arăt cum leg înaintașul, o să vă arăt
cum
sistemele de
plumb pierdut. Ăă, o să vă arăt plumbii
pentru că vreau să vedeți pas cu pas cum
fac eu, cum pescuiesc eu. Dacă printre
voi sunt pescari care deja știu lucrul
ăsta sau care sunt mai experimentați, vă
rog să aveți răbdare pentru că acest
clip este destinat mai mult, să zic,
oamenilor începători sau pescarilor
începători sau pescarilor care nu au
avut șansa până acum să aib multe
partide pe marul apei și să acumuleze
informații informații sau nu au avut
ocazia sau norocul ca mine să am foarte
mulți prieteni pescari care fiecare
descoperă un anumit lucru și stăm de
vorbă și cumva le punem cap la cap. Ok,
toate lucrurile pe care vi le spun aici
sunt descoperite de mine, sunt
descoperite de alți pescari, sunt, să
zic așa, ca baladele populare, da, nu se
știe autorul pentru că sunt luate din
popor. Ok, exact așa este și cu
informațiile pe care eu o să vi le dau.
>> Iertați mă. Așa este și cu informațiile
pe care eu o să vi le dau. Sunt luate
din popor, de acolo ceva, de acolo ceva,
puse cap la cap și făcute strategii pe
ele. Bun, revin imediat ca să vă arăt
cum fac monturile și să vă arăt și
nădirea, să vă arăt și lansările. O să
vă arăt mai multe chestii. Stați cu mine
pân la final. Să vă arăt cum fac eu
nodul de pentru înaintași
și o să vreau să văd dacă după ce fac
nodul trece prin inelele lansetei de
feeder. Eu folosesc niște lansete de
feeder pentru sălbatic, pentru ape
sălbatice.
Sunt lansetele de la Trabuco, Epica Adic
Extreme, iar inelele de la vârfuri sunt
destul de micuțe și o să vreau să văd
dacă reușesc să trec nodul pe acolo.
Bun, ce fac este să iau ambele capete.
Da,
sper că se vede bine pe cameră. Deci au
ambele capete. Am capătul de la firul
meu, firul meu principal și înaintașul
pe care o să l pun. Vă ziceam mai
devreme că vreau să pun înaintaș de
monofilament, ceva gros. Aici am un
0,70, am și 0,90 la mine. O să încep cu
0,70.
Este un fir destinat pescuitului la
somn. Nu m am uitat neapărat la firmă, m
a interesat efectiv mărimea. De fapt, la
magazinul de unde am fost să iau de la
Coubaites aveau Ăsta era cel mai mare.
Eu voiam 0,80 sau 0,90, dar oricum am la
mine și un 0,90 că aveam într o așa.
Bun, deci ce fac este să iau să iau
capetele, da?
Le pun unul peste altul, după care iau
capătul de la firul principal și fac un
fac o buclă și încep să fac un nod
clasic. Da? Deci am făcut bucla și ăsta
ar fi un nodic. Practic fac un nod
clasic peste firul peste înainta și
peste firul de 0,70 și mă duc și bag
prin această buclă de mai multe ori
atunci când folosesc fire subțiri.
bag de nu știu șapte opt ori cu textil
subțire și atunci când folosesc
monofilament cum este acesta, încerc să
nu bag de prea multe ori, de patru ori,
maxim cinci ori este ok. Deci, hai să
vedem. Cred că am băgat de două ori,
trei. Patru. După care strâng ușor.
Da. Îl las așa, nu l strâng de tot. Ok.
Și acum întorc firul.
Și fac același lucru și cu firul de
0,70. Da.
Fac o dată,
de două ori, de trei ori.
Cred că este suficient de trei ori ca să
nu fac nodul prea mare. Ok,
acum trebuie săzim un pic
și după care tragem de capete, nu tragem
de tot. Ăsta fiind un fir, un fir gros,
o să se facă nodul un pic mai greu.
Da. Trag un pic de el. Trag și de
celălalt.
Trebuia să mai trag un pic de ăsta, că
deja a început să se ducă peste
celălalt. Să vedem dacă l salvez.
I am lăsat capătul prea prea mic și nu
pot să trag de el. să trag cu dinții.
Așa. Și acuma trag de ambele.
Și el ar trebui să facă
cam așa. Trag un pic mai tare. Acum
folosesc dinții. Nu recomand treaba
asta, dar n au altă sculă la mine.
Da. Și acuma el este strâns. N este
strâns.
Și ce mi rămâne să fac este doar să tai
surplusurile.
Poți să stai foarte aproape că nodul
ăsta n ar trebui să mai desfacă.
La cel gros am puține emoții.
Fiind gros, este destul de rigid și
da, nu o să se desfacă. Bun. Și acuma
testul suprem. Să vedem dacă trece prin
inelele lansetei.
Trece prin inelele lansetei. Este la
limită.
Oricum noi pescuim aproape de mal. Deci
nu am nevoie să fac lansări mari. Dacă
eu eram pe baltă
sau pe o întinsură și trebuia să fac
lansări la distanță, probabil că nodul
acesta nu m ar fi ajutat absolut deloc.
Da, dar faptul pentru faptul că eu dau
aproape este ok, pot să pescuiesc cu el.
Ok. Și acuma ce o să fac? O să
să las înaintașul
undeva la 7 8 m, dar eu trebuie să mă
gândesc în felul următor. Îmi pregătesc
înaintașul ăsta să văd dacă reușesc să
pescuiesc și la baza pragului. În cazul
în care nu o să am trăsături pe apa de 3
m, o să încerc să mă duc mai aproape, să
mă duc mai pe adâncime, câte puțin, câte
puțin și poate într un final să mă duc
pe apă de 12 m.
Și atunci o să trebuiască să mi las un
înaintaș de 7 8 m. Cam atâta este
coborârea. Cam atâta este pragul unde
coboară. 7 8 m. Și cam atât aș vrea să
las înaintașuri, să nu las nici prea
mult. Ok, asta n o să vă mai arăt cum
fac. Practic, derulez derulez de aici.
Măsor așa ochchiometric. Da. Îmi măsor
7 m, după care mulinez și pun pe pe
tambur. Ok. Bun. Cam asta a fost despre
nod. Asta a fost despre înaintași. O să
mai vorbim pe parcurs despre înaintași
și o să vă zic cum a funcționat.
[Muzică]
Acum vreau să vă vreau să vă arăt
sistemul de plumb pierdut și să vă mai
explic o dată de ce îl folosesc. Din nou
am emoții
cu nodul pentru că acest înaintaș este
mult prea gros. Nu se pescuiește așa de
obicei și am emoții cum voi face aici
nodul. Nu știu dacă va ieși prea bine,
dar dar voi vedea. Bun, în principiu,
ăsta este sistemul de plumb pierdut care
vine cu o agrafă rapidă, două conuri și
sistemul propriu zis de plumb pierdut,
unde se atașează plumbul. Așa.
Cum se face?
Băgăm firul principal, în cazul nostru,
înaintașul,
luăm agrafa rapidă.
Îi facem un nod. Eu o să încerc să i fac
nodul pe care î fac de obicei.
Să vedem dacă și reușesc cu acest fir
gros.
Foarte, foarte gros. Foarte țepos firul
ăsta. L am dat doar de trei ori.
Cred că este suficient.
Să încerc să
mzesc.
Acum trag și ar trebui să bag capătul
prin bucla care s a creat sus. Da. Și să
trag până se strânge. Doar că e foarte
greu să se strângă acest nod pentru că
este
firul prea gros. O să încerc și cu
dinții.
Ușor, ușor.
Hai că am reușit să fac ceva.
La fel. Tăiem surplusul și aici.
Și acum sistemul
trebuie să tragă
grafa rapidă. Să vedem dacă trece
nodul.
Nu prea trece. Normal trebuia să intre
mai mult, dar văd că nu o face.
Dar este suficient.
Nu am greșit ceva. Aici trebuia să pun
conul.
Conul acesta de sus pe care nici nu l am
scos.
Dar nu i problemă că tai și mai fac o
dată. Cu ocazia asta mai vedeți o dată
cum se face nodul.
Și cei care n aveți răbdare puteți să i
dați să i dați așa pe for înainte.
Ok,
deci varianta corectă este în felul
următor.
Luăm conul mic, da? Îl introducem pe
firul principal
sau înaintaș, după care luăm sistemul,
introducem,
facem un nod.
Iar vă zic dacă aici aș fi folosit fir
textil sau un fir mai subțire.
aș fi
dat firul de mai multe ori. Eu acum o să
l dau doar de trei ori, dar la fir
textil dau de ște opt ori pentru că
acela alunecă, iar la monofilament
cinciș ori este suficient. Da. Bag prin
bucla de jos,
după care încerc să strâng. Aici se sus
se creează o buclă. Ok.
capătul o să l bag pe aici.
Încerc să strâng
puțin dintr o parte, puțin dintr o
parte.
Și nodul este făcut. Este aproape
perfect. Nu urmărim perfecțiunea cu
acest fir. Acum este un fir grosolan.
Da. Tăiem surplusul din nou.
Și acum am făcut cum trebuie.
Deci firul ăsta, firul ăsta îmi dă îmi
dă bătăie de cap. Deci așa arată
sistemul nostru de împierdut.
Aici am zis că trebuia să intre mai
mult, dar nu o face pentru că nodul este
prea mare. Și
aici se adaugă
plumbul,
după care se trage cu unul peste.
Haide, mă.
Ok.
Bun. Ce sunt aici? O să Aici o să punem
o să punem rigul cu acest con și o să
vină așa. O să legăm imediat și un rig
ca să vă arăt
care este, să zicem, avantajul cel mai
mare pe care îl are acest sistem.
Gândiți vă în felul următor. Ajunge
montura pe substrat. Da. Și plumbul
acesta intră în pietre. Dacă el este
blocat în pietre și noi tragem cu putere
sau peștele trage cu putere, de aici se
va elibera plumbul. Ok, dacă noi tr ia
să vedem dacă reușim. Dacă noi tragem
acuma cu putere vedeți deja plumbul
începe să să se facă loc aici și se
eliberează plumbul. Ok, în unele cazuri
se și rupe, ăă, dar ăă noi avem șansa să
scoatem peștele și cu plumb pierdut să
știți că protejăm un pic și peștii
pentru că nu va mai rămâne peștele în
cazul în care ni se rupe firul
principal, nu va mai rămâne peștele
agățat în
în pietre în cioate cu plumbul, adică
plumbul agățat acolo și peștele cu
cârligul în gură. Da.
Dacă se eliberează dacă se eliberează,
se rupe firul principal. Oricum poate să
iasă poate să iasă firul de aici. Rămâne
doar cu firul în gură și vă asigur că el
va scăpa de cârlig în următoarea
perioadă dacă nu are plumbul atașat care
să se blocheze undeva și peștele să
rămână acolo să nu mai aibă ce să facă.
Ok, deci asta este asta este montura cu
plumbier. Poate că mulți dintre voi
știți cum se face, poate că unii doar ce
ați văzut. Eu o recomand doar în
situațiile în care pescuim pe prag.
Pescuim în prag și în prag de
nisip sau prag de pământ o recomand
pentru că la fel acolo se poate bloca
plungul și poate rămâne acolo și o
recomand cu mare drag și cu mare
eficiență pe pe brațul sulina. Ok, acum
urmează să leg un rig, să leg un cârlig,
să vă arăt cum leg rigurile cu fir
cămășuit pentru pescuitul cu plumb
pierdut. O să fac riguri, dar haideți că
vă povestesc imediat cu riguri de 25 cm
și cum se leagă.
Am terminat de legat înaintașul de
sistemul de plumb pierdut și acum
urmează să leg un rig. O să leg un rig
cămășuit. Am aici un fir cămășuit la
Carp Spirit.
Vă rog să mă scuzați, mi s a uscat gura.
Am un fir că mă șiit de la card Spirit.
Bun, ce o să fac? O să tai o bucată de
fir.
O să decămășuiesc cu dinții,
bineînțeles, pentru că nu am alt sistem.
Aici la legatul cârgicelor cu fir
cămășuit este cum să zic eu pe testare.
Da, nu știu să vă zic cât trebuie să
decămășuiți ca să vă iasă rigul perfect.
O să vă arăt cum preferă unii pescari să
fie rigul și cum cum fac eu rigurile.
Adică cumva eu nu țin nu țin cont de
lucrul ăsta, dar o să vă arăt cum
preferă unii pescari. Bun, deci am de
cămășuit o bucată de fir. Acuma urmează
să fac o buclă.
Da, o buclă simplă.
Tăiem din nou surplusul.
Foarfeca mea nu mai taie prea bine.
Mi a mai căzut pe jos. Așa. Bun. După ce
am făcut buclă, o să băgăm un boilis.
Aici am un boilis de 20 mm.
Căpșună
din gama cireașa de pe tort.
Băgăm
disul. Luăm un opritor. Vă recomand
aceste opritoare să le folosiți. Mie îmi
plac foarte mult, dar na, sunt fel și
fel de opritoare pe piață.
Așa,
băgăm opritorul prin
bucla pe care am făcut o mai devreme.
Știți cum e, când e în fața camerei, nu
ți iese din prima.
Așa. Bun. Și acuma o să iau un cârlig.
Haideți să vă arăt un pic că vă ziceam,
cred că v am zis mai devreme de alegerea
alegerea mărimii cârligului. Da, dacă
vedeți aici, eu am un cârlig de la un
producător și spune pe el că este
mărimea patru. Da, mărimea 4u din
perspectiva mea și din experiența mea cu
alte cârlige este mai mare decât acesta.
Deci acesta de la acest producător,
mărimea 4 este de fapt mărimea 6. Ok. Și
cum putem să verificăm, cum verific eu
dacă este ok cârligul pentru
bilă sau pentru peletă este în felul
următor: să îl pun pe lângă bilă și să
nu fie mai mare decât bila, să nu fie cu
mult mai mic decât bila. Da, eu după ce
o să leg cârligul o să vedeți că o să
arate ceva de genul ăsta. Ok?
Și atunci când crapul vine și absoarbe
bila, când încearcă s o scuipe că simte
ceva, că nu e în regulă, simte cârligul,
el se va agăța. Dacă cârligul este prea
mic, atunci nu se va
e posibil să nu se agațe ca mecanica să
nu fie să nu fie ok. Și dacă este prea
mare, este posibil să l simtă peștele
înainte de a l de a l trage, de a l
absorbi. Ok. Bun. Hai să vedem următorul
pas.
Hai să vedem următorul pas.
Urmează să legăm cârligul. Întotdeauna
luăm capătul opus care ne a rămas și l
băgăm prin spatele cârligului. Da, prin
spatele tijei. Deci întotdeauna vine
prin spatele tijei. Și acuma setăm
distanța firului de păr. Ok? Ăă trebuie
să aveți grijă aici un pic este posibil
să vă să vă fure dacă voi setați
distanța atât și o să legați. În
momentul în care voi o să legați,
distanța voastră o să fie atât. Deci,
întotdeauna încercați s o lăsați un pic
mai lângă decât vă decât vă vă propuneți
voi să fie. Da? E Mie îmi place cam
distanța asta. Nici prea mare, da, nici
prea mică. Mie îmi place o distanță
medie. Da, cam asta este distanța pe
care
eu o folosesc și mie îmi place.
Și ce o să fac? O să i mai dau încă
puțin drumul pentru că știu că o să se
strângă în momentul în care eu voi
matisa. Ok, acuma ce fac este să
țin cârligul cu degetele stânci împreună
cu firul ca firul să nu se miște. Ok. Și
încep să matez. Dacă vă uitați voi și
sper că se vede bine pe cameră, cârligul
în fabrică este îndoit din partea asta
și se termină aici. Și aici este partea
unde a fost îndoit. Eu încep întotdeauna
să fac
matisarea opus părții unde s a îndoit.
De ce? Ca să nu risc vreodată să iasă
firul pe aici. Ok. Și încep. Deci cred
că toate cârligele, dacă nu mă înșel,
sunt făcute în felul ăsta. Și eu încep
de jos, nu de sus. Da, deci de jos și
matisez câte spire dau eu aici, cât
matisez. De obicei nu le număr. Sau și
dacă le număr mă duc până trec un pic de
vârful cârligului. Da, deci cam atât am
trecut. Acum, pentru că noi folosim
folosim fir cămășuit și să zicem că la
firul cămășuit vrem cămașa
să ne rămână fix aici sau să avem două
spire, să avem o spiră sau două pe
cârlig, ar trebui să matisăm mai mult.
Da? sau invers. Dacă nu am decămășuit ă
suficient și vedem că deja am atisat
jumate și suntem suntem la la cămașă,
ajungem firul unde are ajungem la firul
la firul unde are cămașă atunci putem să
lăsăm mai puțin. Da, eu în cazul meu pot
să mai dau două spire. Ok, chiar trei.
Mă duc și mă întorc înapoi. Da. Mai dau
două spire și dacă vedeți voi, a treia
spiră este deja pe firul cămășuit.
Ok? Deci așa preferă, așa preferă foarte
mulți pescari să pescuiască cu firul,
adică firul cămășuit să aibă o spiră sau
două aici în spatele pe tijă. Da, eu mai
fac chiar dacă nu chiar câteodată nu mi
iese bine. Acuma de ce să de ce să zic?
Câteodată nu mi iese bine? Îmi iese așa
și îmi iese să zic că rămâne textilul,
îmi rămâne o bucată de aici până aici.
Ok. Nu m a deranjat cu nimic până acum,
nu am sesizat că este ceva nasol. Nu mi
s a rupt firul de aici. Adică cumva a
fost ok. Da, dar i am arătat i am arătat
un rigosteluș.
râdea de mine. Ce la cum ai lega rigul
ăla, la cum aș rugat cârligul ăla, n are
cum să vină peștele să mănânce la el
pentru că nu făcusem sppir asta aici.
El, el e oarecum, cum să zic eu, ține
mult la cum arată rigul. Da. Bun. Și așa
arată rigul nostru. Poate că firul de de
păr este un pic cam lunguț dar nu este o
problemă dacă este lung. Bun, acuma
vreau să vă arăt cum cum este mecanica
de fapt a acestui cârlig. Da. Gândiți vă
că el așa stă pe substrat. Da, peștele o
să vină, o să absoarbă. În momentul în
care el absoarbe bila, cârligul intră în
gură. El când începe, că el simte
cârligul, el, nu știu dacă pescuiți pe
Dunăre și pe bălți. Presupun că ați
văzut că în majoritatea peștilor, în
majoritatea cazurilor înțepătura este de
buză. Asta de ce? Pentru că el,
înțepătoarea se face când el încearcă să
scuipe
ce a absorbit pentru că simte că ceva nu
este în regulă. Da. Și atunci se agață
cârligul. Sunt foarte puține cazurile,
sunt foarte rare cazurile în care
cârligul este agățat undeva din
interior, adică peștele s a dus mult, a
luat, a încercat să ducă în dinții
faringieni bila. Ok? Pentru că el simte
pericolul și atunci scuipă cârligul. În
momentul în care el scuipă cârligul,
dacă mecanica este bună, cârligul el
este echilibrat cu
cu boilis ul se va agăța de buza lui din
lateral, de jos
de sus nu prea. Dacă se agață de sus
ceva nu e ok. La mecanica cârligului.
Ok. Bun. Și cam asta este. Deci el
absoarbe și în momentul în care încearcă
să scuipe datorită gravitației, pentru
că centrul de greutate este jos la
cârlig, cârligul va sta întotdeauna așa
în apă. Ok. Și atunci când peștele îl
scuipă, se va întâmpla chestia asta și
se produce înțepare. Ok, cam asta este
logica
înțepării, logica absorbrii și a
înțepării și logica
firului cămășuit este pentru protecție,
este pentru zonele cu scoici, unde sunt
multe scoici. Ia uitați că Marius are un
run. Și ce run are?
[Muzică]
Este un ciortan, dar este prima captură
a noastră din această partidă.
Bravo, Marius!
Deci, a venit primul pește la Marius.
Este foarte bine. Avem speranțe.
Bun, hai să continuăm discuția noastră.
Vă spuneam de firul cămășuit. De ce l
folosim? Îl folosim acolo unde pescuim
în praguri, unde pescuim pe scoică, unde
este scoică pe praguri și unde
pescuim în piatră. Bun. Acum mai avem
mai avem de făcut bucla din spate și să
i facem lungimea. Să i setăm lungimea
rigului. Ok, aici o să iau conul.
Este conul care vine la sistemul de de
plumb pierdut,
după care setez lungimea rigului. Eu am
aici un penar. Penarul ăsta are
aproximativ 25 de cm de aici până aici.
Ok, deci eu fac rigurile cam de 25 de de
cm ca să mi intre în penar. Și aici fac
o buclă simplă.
De fapt, o buclă nu e chiar simplă. Fac
o buclă și bucla pe care am făcut o o
bag de
trei ori.
După care strâng,
tăm surplusul.
Așa. Și acum ce urmează să facem este să
atașăm
la
lumbul nostru. Avem
aici o agrafă rapidă în pus, după care
tragem conul până pe agrafa rapidă. O să
fie mai greu aici pentru că
nodul este mai gros.
Da.
Și așa arată montura noastră. Da. Asta
este montura pe care o folosesc în
partida de astăzi
pentru
pescuitul doar la bile. O să pescuiesc
cu două cu două lansete și la monitor și
o să vă arăt acolo cum fac la fel rigul,
cum fac
cum fac montura. Efectiv am promis că vă
arăt cum se leagă cârligul atunci când
pescuiesc cu momitoare. De fapt cum se
face montura completă pentru pescuitul
cu momitoare. Bine, nu este mare lucru.
Cârligele se leagă la fel cum v am
arătat că se leagă și la firul cămășuit,
doar că lungimea rigului este mai mică
și în loc de plumb pierdut punem
momitoare cu un fund plat. Bun. Eu
recomand aceste momitoare pe în
pescuitul pe ape sălbatice și nu nu
neapărat doar pe ape sălbatice și pe și
pe bălți private pentru că are fundul
plat și el va cădea întotdeauna așa. Da?
Deci el va cădea cu nada în sus și aici
în nadă noi băgăm peleta noastră sau
bila noastră. Da, de asta și zice
cireașa de pe tort pentru că nada este
tortul și peleta sau bila este cireașa.
Ok? momitoarele acestea pe care eu le
folosesc acum. M ați întrebat mulți unde
le de unde puteți să le luați și
[Muzică]
am decis să facem și noi un model de
momitor. Încă suntem în stadiul de
stadiul de proiect. O să facem ceva
similar, tot așa cu fund plat, doar că
această tijă va fi înlocuită și aici va
fi o gaură care i va permite vârtejului
sau agrafei rapide să intre aici, să se
semiblocheze cumva, să aibă și o
autonțepare. Acest model de momitor are
o problemă foarte mare. Cei care î
folosiți știți deja lucrul acesta. Tija
aceasta se sparge după câteva folosi sau
poate chiar din primă se sparge. Dacă el
ajunge prin pietre, se sparge tija și
atunci trebuie înlocuit monitorul. În
rest el ok. O să încercăm să facem
pentru noi un monitor mai bun. Ok, dar
na, durează. Ok. O să vedeți probabil pe
pagina noastră de TikTok, de Facebook. O
să sau direct pe site ul nostru când o
să fie gata. Ok, deci astea sunt
monomitarele pe care eu le folosesc și v
am zis și de ce le folosesc, ce mecanică
îmi oferă ele mie pe substrat. Da, hai
să ne apucăm de legat cărlice. V am zis,
nu este mare lucru. Este la fel. Am
tăiat o bucată de fir textil. De data
asta folosesc doar fir textil. Nu mai
folosesc cămășuit. De ce? Pentru că voi
folosi un rig de 15 cm. Fiind de 15 cm,
șansele ca el să se rupă în drill în
pietre este un pic mai mică. De ce?
Pentru că peștele vine gândiți vă că
aici este cârligul. Peștele vine ia
cârligul de pe momitor sau de lângă
momitor și după care se ridică se ridică
un pic în coloana de apă în sus și
atunci se duce și
și ridică și momitorul și ridică și
cârligul, adică rigul nostru și nu avem
risc atât de mare să se rupă să se rupă
rigul. Ok. Bun. Acum,
deci iar Marius este în drill. Cum e
Marius? S a agățat.
Da, a avut o trăsătură. S a agățat.
Deci, prima și prima dată, prima și
prima dată o să facem o să facem rig ul.
O să facem bucla.
Da, facem o buclă simplă.
A, încă ceva. Eu acum o să folosesc
pelete și probabil v am mai zis în
clipurile mele de ce la pelete eu
folosesc fir de păr. Pentru că vreau să
fiu sigur că firul meu de păr va rămâne,
că peleta mea va rămâne cât mai mult
atașată la cârlig. Dacă aș folosi spin,
este posibil să am pește mic pe vad, să
am un ciortan ceva sau caras care să mi
fure efectiv peleta și eu să rămân acolo
cu montura timp de 40 de minute, o oră,
să cred că am peletă și cânc colo eu să
nu am. Da? Și atunci eu merg pe
prevenție și folosesc folosesc firul de
păr. Da, exact cum vă arăt eu acum să vă
arăt de ce v am zis eu că prefer firul
de păr pentru pelete, pentru că avem
șansa să rămână la cârlig până se top.
Uitați aici exemplul peleta asta o am o
am la cârlig, o am în apă de o oră și
jumătate și încă încă a rămas pe firul
de păr. Deci am făcut am făcut prima
dată o buclă, după care o să iau o
peletă.
Avem aici peletele de 15 mm.
Da.
Introduc prin coșetă. Încă ceva mai
voiam să vă zic în legătură cu
croșetele. Mare atenție ce croșete
folosiți. După cum vedeți, croșeta pe
care eu o folosesc este o croșetă
subțirică. Da, este o croșetă care nu
sparge produsul, care nu crapă produsul.
Am mai primit de la clienți
un feedback pe anumite produse, cum că
ele se crapă și mi am dat seama că la
unii dintre ei era vorba de croșeta pe
care o foloseau că foloseau o croșetă
groasă și atunci ce vă recomand este să
luați cea mai subțire croșetă pe care o
găsiți la magazin pentru că va fi ok. Nu
se va rupe, vă vă asigur. Eu aici cred
că am ceva de la delfini. Da. Așa. Deci
am luat
am introdus peleta.
Am nevoie acum de un stopper. Unde sunt
stopper?
Pentru bineînțeles
îi pun un stopper.
Vrei să ți iasă din prima? Nu ți iese
din prima.
Așa.
Acum ce i mai fac eu? Ce mi place mie să
fac la peletă, la bilă de obicei nu fac
treaba asta. Îi pun un opritor de
silicon. Peleta se se topește repede și
nu vreau ca ea să ca ea să se miște să
se miște în jurul să se miște pe firul
de păr. Este doar alegerea mea. Nu știu
dacă este 100% nevoie de el. În unele
cazuri s ar putea să nu aveți nevoie.
Dacă vreți să faceți la fel ca mine,
puteți să faceți. Dacă faceți fără este
la fel de bine. Ok, deci eu îi pun și un
opritor de silicon sau cauciuc, ce este
ăsta, după care urmează să leg cârligul.
Vă aduceți aminte ce v am spus puțin mai
devreme, cum alegem cârligele atunci
când când vrem să legăm o momeală și am
zis cârligul să nu fie mai mare decât
decât momeala pe care o aveți și să nu
fie mult prea mic. Aici eu am un cârlig
pe BD6.
Normal, eu îl văd cam de om. Cei acest
producător ăă mi se pare că
are așa un decalaj pe mărimea cârligor.
Da, deci cam așa arată cârligul dacă vă
uitați în comparație cu peleta mea, ceea
ce este suficient pentru mine. Ok. Bun.
După care iau capătul care mi a rămas
și o să îl introduc prin spate. Vă
aduceți aminte? Întotdeauna prin spate.
Da, am introdus prin spate. Setez
distanța firului de păr. La pelete eu
pot să mă duc un pic mai aproape decât
la bilă. Da, pot să mă duc undeva pe
aici.
Corect.
Țin cu mâna stângă firul și
matisez.
Eu
pentru siguranță matisez și înapoi de
câteva ori,
după care capătul îl bag din nou prin
spatele cârligului. Ok.
Așa.
Și distanța optimă pentru
peleta mea. Ok, deci așa arată cârligul
legat. Dacă voi vă uitați acum cu
cârligul acesta D6 de la PB, pare un pic
cam agresivă montura. Pare un pic cam
agresivă. Este cuvântul potrivit. Ăă
peștele când va veni și l va lu prinde
direct cârligul, asta i clar. Eu
obișnuiesc să folosesc cârlige mai mici
pentru pelete de 15 mm, cârlig de 8, dar
fiind vară, fiind, peștele se hrănește,
să zicem, destul de bine. Cel puțin cei
care au avut trăsături până acum au avut
plecări direct pe ran. Deci n au fost
ciupituri, n au fost, eu știu, cum am
pățit eu în alte în alte partide în care
ciupeau cinciște minute la o peletă și
abia după aia o luau. Și atunci un
cârlig un cârlig de genul ăsta este ok.
Nu, nu este nicio problemă cu el. Dacă
peștele ar fi fost mofturos, atunci aș
fi folosit cârlig de opt sau chiar de
10. Da. Bun. Acum o să setez lungimea
rigului. Eu o să i fac să l fac
aproximativă. Ziceam ieri că am măsurat
acest penar și de aici până aici eu am
în jur de 25 cm. Da? Și atunci eu o să l
fac eu o să l fac undeva cam pe aici
aproximez eu că ar fi 15 cm. Acuma că
sunt 16 că sau că sunt 13 cm nu este
nicio problemă. Da, am aproximat.
Fac același aceeași același nodătat
mai devreme.
Fac o buclă și introduc de trei ori.
Numai să mi și iasă din prima.
E un pic greu că stau și în spatele
camerei și nu văd prea bine. Mă chinui
să văd ce fac.
Deci 1 2
și 3. Da, am strâns.
S a format bucla.
Tăiem surplusul. Mi a rămas cam mult
surplus.
Ok.
Și așa arată rigul meu. Da, ăsta este un
rig clasic. Nu este nimic complicat la
el. Nu este nimic greu. Nu este greu de
făcut. Este foarte ușor de realizat.
Dacă plecați la pescuit, vă faceți
dinainte 20 30 de riguri de acasă, ca să
nu mai stați să legați cum fac eu
aproape de fiecare dată pe apă.
Așa. Și acum urmează să pun momitorul.
Ia să vedem unde mi este firul.
Cum punemitorul? Momitorul este foarte
simplu de pus.
Introducem
firul prin con,
după care prin momitor.
Așa. Și acuma aici trebuie să legăm un
un eu folosesc un Quick Change, o agrafă
rapidă. Vă arăt imediat cum arată. Mai
voiam să vă zic ceva. Ați mai văzut în
clipurile mele că eu folosesc opritor
aici pe fir. Folosesc opritorul pe fir
de multe ori sau să zicem în majoritatea
cazelor în care pescuiesc din barcă. De
ce? Pentru că în barcă de multe ori las
firul să fie mai moale, deci nu l țin
tensionat pe vârf. Da. Nu, nu l țin
tensionat pe vârf. Las să fie mai moale
și atunci când peștele vine și
[Muzică]
ia peleta, ia cârligul meu, nu vreau să
l las
să ia ceva care este moale. Da, adică să
iau un fir care este moale și să nu se
producă un tonțeparea. Și atunci îi pun
aici pe fir înainte de momitor un
opritor de silicon
care acela în cazul de ruptură se
eliberează și peștele scapă de momitor.
Acum că pescuiesc de pe mal nu este
cazul. De ce? pentru că oricum eu am
firele,
n aș zice super întinse, dar destul de
întinse și atunci peștele când vine
oricum pentru că eu am firul întins și
el când trage cu greutatea monitorului
și cu frâna mulinetei se produce
autoțeparea și atunci n am nevoie acum
de un opritor aici. Dar v am zis ca să
știți sau v am zis pentru cei care v ați
mai uitat și ați văzut la mine că
folosesc
opritor acolo.
Ok, eu am niște quick change uri
luate de pe ceva site chinezesc. Le am
văzut eu și m au atras și acuma le
folosesc. Nu pot să zic că sunt adică
sunt interesante,
dar cred că s ar s ar potrivi mult mai
bine cu acesta, s ar potrivi mai bine pe
un pe un alt tip de de monitor.
Așa. Deci trebuie să scot Am scos partea
de plastic.
Introduc firul
și aici o să fac nodul
care vi l am mai arătat. Mai fac o dată.
Este un fir de este un fir am un fir
monofilament gros. Ăsta este un fir cred
că de 0,45. Fac direct pe linia
principală
pentru că monitorele se pescuiesc mai
aproape decât dau cu plumii normali și
am observat ieri că n am avut nicio
ruptură. zona pe unde unde dau cu
momitoarele pare destul de curată, nu
pare să aibă multe pietre și atunci pot
să folosesc direct firul principal. În
cazul în care o să am rupturi, o să o să
schimb firul principal și o să pun
înaintașul acela de 0,70.
Ok, deci am dat cred că de două ori trei
ori, nu știu exact. Mai dau o dată și îl
traduc. Deci băgăm prima dată prin bucla
de jos. Strângem un pic, îl umezim.
Da. Bucla care s a format sus, băgăm și
prin ea capătul, strângem
și începe să formeze nodul. Este un nod
foarte rezistent.
Acum tăiem surplusul
și urmează să atașăm cârligul pe care
noi l am legat.
Am pus cârligul
și acum
tragem partea de plastic de bine cred că
e cauciuc.
Și așa arată montura noastră. Da.
Peletă, rig,
momitor.
Și aici, în cazul în care este nevoie un
opritor. Da, peleta va veni aici. Cireșa
de pe tort. Imediat o să vă arăt cum se
face și cu nadă. I am mai dat un pic de
apă, după care mi am umezit mâna. Asta
vă recomand și vouă să faceți. De
fiecare dată când puneți nadă pe
momitor, vă umeziți mâna și o frământați
un pic înainte ca să i dați textura
aceea de
nadă legată, se lege mai bine și să fie
maleabilă. Ok.
Și acum, după ce am frământat o bine în
mână,
urmează să o pun pe momitor.
Am pus o pe momitor.
Da. O uniformizez un pic,
strâng bine.
După care fac o gaură în mijloc cu
degetul mare sau orice deget și introduc
pelet. Da,
am introdus peleta.
Uneori îi pun și pe cârlig. Puțină nadă.
De data asta n o să i mai pun și pe
cârlig.
Îi pun și pe cârlig sau pot să îngrop un
pic cârligul. Ok.
Și din punctul meu de vedere, asta este
prezentarea perfectă pe substrat
cu monitor pentru sălbatic. Bineînțeles,
aici un pic de un pic de nad ar fi
trebuit pe deasupra. Da, deci asta este
cireașa de pe tort. Eu de asta de asta
toată gama noastră de de produse de
cârlig se numește cireașa de pe tort
pentru că exact așa arată și așa a fost
gândită pentru astfel de monturi. Ok,
acum voi lansa, voi aștepta în jur de 40
de minute, după care voi le scoate, iar
voi le lansa și tot așa. Să vă arăt cum
fac și nădirea. Am aici mai multe bile
de 20 de 24 fish meal, Burood, roșii,
galbene. Am făcut așa un mix complet. O
să nădesc un pic în amonte.
Curentul acum nu este puternic. Nu este
foarte puternic. O să nădesc un pic în
amonte în stile vantai cu mâna. Normal
ar fi trebuit să am o paletă de nădit la
mine, dar nu am. O să nădesc un pic în
amunte cu mâna. Bilele o să cadă în fața
mea sau după mine sau înaintea mea la
câțiva metri. Și ăla este patul meu de
nadă. Ok.
Nădeți destul de aproape pentru că v am
zis pragul pragul nostru este aproape.
Dau un pic și mai în stânga și mai în
dreapta pentru că vreau să fac un pat de
nadă mai mare, dar oarecum pe aceeași
linie ca peștele chiar dacă vine din
partea aia să l găsească să înceapă să
mănânce bile pe el și să vină până la
urmă să găsească și locul unde am eu
puse
monturile.
[Muzică]
Am făcut nădirea.
Mi au mai rămas câteva bile aici. O să
mai îmi fac un mix de bile și o să
încerc să țin să nădesc din oră în oră
sau dacă nu măcar din două ore în două
ore ca să dau câteva mâini să fie bile
pe vad de fiecare dată când peștii trec
prin zonă ei trebuie să găsească bile pe
vad să rămână acolo. Ok, cam asta a fost
cu nădirea. Revin cu alte cu alte
lucruri. Bună dimineața. Suntem în a
doua zi de pescuit. De fapt, hai să
spune prima zi de pescuit pentru că ieri
am pescuit câteva ore. Să vă fac așa un
mic update ce s a întâmplat ieri. Eu am
stat de filmat până am lansat lansetele
la apă, până am făcut câteva clipuri
despre montură, băieții au reușit să se
instaleze. Înaintea mea am reușit și eu
într un final să mă instalez. Am pescuit
și eu în jur de patru ore. Eu n am scos
nimic, n am scos niciun pește. În
schimb, Marius a avut doi ciortani și o
ruptură.
Fratele meu a avut și el doi pești sau
trei și fiecare dintre ei a avut câte un
pește sau o ruptură.
Cam cam cam astea s rezultatele de ieri.
Am făcut nădire în continuare aseară.
Ieri am nădit constant cu bile la să zic
la o oră, o oră și jumătate. Băieții la
fel au nădit și ei în
dreptul lor. Acuma mă uitam, mă uitam la
Marius că
se aude un senzor. Noi suntem pe mal și
toți avem roodpod, senzori. Na, că la
fel ca pescuitul pe baltă.
Cam atât. Cam asta s a întâmplat ieri.
Astăzi începem din nou pescuitul.
Băieții la fel au fost mai vrei ca mine.
Deja au toate lansetele în apă. Eu am
două lansete rupte pentru că ieri când
am recuperat s a rupt.
Testul acela pe care l am făcut cu
firul de 0070,
el funcționează, este ok, recomand să
fie folosit. Dar ce cred eu că am greșit
ieri
de fapt am greșit. Ăsta este produsul.
Sistemul de la
plumbul pierdut am impresia că este un
pic cam rigid și nu se rupe, nu se rupe
sau nu, nu se desface plumbul de acolo.
Am Am pierdut ieri vreo patru monturi
care s au rupt de la înainta, de la
firul de la înaintaș și mi a lăsat
impresia că plumbul s a blocat în pietre
și sistemul de
de plumb pierdut nu și a făcut treaba.
Astăzi o să schimb. Mai am câteva la
mine din
de la un alt brand și o să încerc să văd
dacă dacă asta a fost problema. Și ieri
ce mi s a întâmplat
un
la o lansetă am scos fără cârlig, deși
era firul cămășuit, dar am, mă rog, am
scos pentru că am tras tare, tot așa era
agățat. Era clar cârligul se agățase
într o piatră și atunci s a rupt firul
cămășuit. Asta este ăsta este singurul
lucru. Adică de când folosesc fir
cămășuit, e prima dată când se rupe se
rupe de la rig, dar oricum foarte
rezistent. Ar trebuit să trag foarte
tare de el ca să să l rupi. Îmi este un
pic cam greu să folosesc și camera, să
și pescuiesc. Nu știu, nu prea încă n am
găsit o variantă bună încât să pot să
fac ambele lucruri deodată, să și
filmez și să și pescuiesc. Cumva
filmatul îmi răpește mult din timpul de
pescuit și nu pot să fiu focusat pe
pescuit și bineînțeles se mai întâmplă
lucruri cum se întâmplă acum în spatele
meu. Cei de la cazare trec cu un ATV
prin spate.
Normal ar trebui să reiau cadrul să
refac chestia asta, dar nu o să mai fac
asta pentru că pierd din timpul de
pescuit și nu nu vreau așa. Bun, deci
cam asta este astăzi. O să încerc să
filmez și cu telefonul în cazul în care
sunt drilluri la băieți.
[Muzică]
Am riscat Un pic m am dus pe adâncime pe
apă de 12 m, exact așa cum
cum am zis. Peștele stă la adâncime și
am început să să prind. Este aruncată de
jumătate de oră.
O să mai scot o lansetă. O bag și pe aia
pe 12 m, tot așa cu un înaintaș de 0,70.
Am avut noroc că am reușit să l scot.
Dacă vă uitați aici
plumbul s a pierdut și asta m a ajutat
foarte mult pentru că nu s a agățat în
pietre.
Deci astrele s au aliniat.
[Muzică]
Vă salut, dragi pescari. Este a treia zi
de pescuit. Aseară băieții noștri au
stat de noapte, au pescuit de noapte și
au luat un crap pe la vreo 4 kg. Au mai
luat și doi ciortani, au mai avut câteva
trăsături, dar i au ratat.
Astăzi, în jur de ora 10:00, am luat și
eu un un crap pe la vreo 3 kg.
Este exact așa cum mă așteptam. Cum v am
zis și la început, cota este în scădere,
peștele stă la adâncime.
Peștii pe care i am prins cei puțin, cel
puțin cei mai mărceii, la 3 kg, 3,5 4, i
am luat de pe adânc. Ăă v am zis că am
băgat ieri am avut trei lansete. Prima
dată am început cu o lansetă pe
adâncime. Am luat de acolo la jumătate
de oră a intrat un pește, după care am
băgat trei pe adâncime și până seara n
am mai avut nicio trăsătură. Pe seară a
intrat un pește la A intrat un pește la
o lansetă și cam atât. Peștii sunt pe
apa adâncă. Am ieșit cu barca să mă uit
totuși cu sonarul. Să uit o dată cu
sonarul să văd cum este pragul.
Este destul de departe. Baza pragului
este destul de departe. Nu prea reușesc
să ajung cu lanseta pentru că
am lansetele de 2,70 m și am pus și
firul înainta de 0,70 0,70. Da. A și
când iese prin inele faci.
Deci nu nu reușesc să să ajung până la
baza pragului, dar undeva pe 10 pe 10 11
m pescuiesc. Eu am crezut că pescuiesc
pe 12 m direct, dar nu ajung până acolo.
Oricum, de acolo am avut trăsături.
[Muzică]
Pe pragul de 3 m aici nu se prinde nu se
prinde pește, dar este normal pentru că
cota este încă scădere și a scăzut și a
scăzut și presiunea atmosferică. Deci e
clar, peștele stă stă la adâncime.
Mai avem niște prieteni pe lacrian. au
reușit să scoată astăzi un pește mai
mare, un cred că un 10 kg, dar nu o
frecvență mare. Ei pescuiesc direct pe
apă de 12 m, pescuiesc din barcă.
Iar pe grupurile de pescari nu prea se
aude nimic cum că cum încă s ar prinde
cine știe ce. Na, este o perioadă în
care nu merge atât de bine peștele și
dacă vă aduceți aminte că vorbeam noi,
vorbeam eu mai devreme în clipul acesta
despre condițiile care ne ajută să
prindem pește sau să nu prindem pește.
Ei bine, asta este una dintre condițiile
în care partidele de pescuit nu sunt
foarte reușite. Cele mai cele mai
reușite partide de pescuit sunt atunci
când cota este
cota este stabilă, când
presiunea atmosferică este stabilă și
temperatura apei în funcție de anotimp,
pentru că s a prins pește foarte bine și
pe temperaturi scăzută, pe temperaturi
scăzute și pe temperaturi mari a apei.
Ideea e în felul următor. Vara, peștele
se plimbă mult, stă mult pe scenal, stă
în brațele principale și se plimbă. Se
plimbă mult. Da, dacă astăzi ai prins
pește pe o zonă, mâine e posibil să nu
mai prinzi pentru că el nu este în zona
respectivă, s a dus în altă parte. În
schimb, toamna, iarna și primăvara,
pescuitul devine un pic mai mai frumos
pentru noi pescarii, pentru că peștele
se strânge pe gropi, se strânge pe
structuri, se cantonează, se strânge la
un loc, stă mult în bancuri și atunci
dacă noi găsim o structură de genul ăla,
avem șanse foarte mari să prindem.
În schimb, de pe mal, iarna și toamna
este cam același lucru, un pic mai
dificil de prins.
De ce vă dau toate informațiile astea?
pentru că îmi doresc ca în viitor
să
nu zic neapărat să educăm piața, ci să
dăm informații utile pescarilor ca să nu
mai aud afirmația că nada X nu e bună,
nada y nu a adus rezultate. Pentru că vă
dau exemplu clar, exemplul în care eu
sunt acum. Credeți mă că am dat foarte
multe bile pe pragul de 3 m. foarte
foarte multe bile pe pragul de 3 m și nu
nu s a strâns peștele aici. Nu s a
strâns pentru că nu îi permite corpul.
El vrea să stea la adâncime. Stă la
adâncime din motive de siguranță și din
motive de
din siguranță și din confort. Ok?
nu o să fie dispus ca el să vină să
mănânce bilele mele pe pragul de 3 m,
având în vedere că peștele pe sălbatic
are foarte multă mâncare, foarte multă
scoică, mulți raci, mulți melci. De ce
ar veni el apă de 3 m ca să mănânce
niște bile când el are la apă de 12 m?
Da, el are
are hrană la 12 m și vreau să vă fac să
înțelegeți că nu nada este cea care
prinde pește de fiecare dată. Într
adevăr, avem nevoie de o nadă corectă,
da? Nu zicem o nadă de top, zicem o nadă
corectă și trebuie să punem accent
foarte mult pe localizarea peștelui și
pe strategia pe care noi o aplicăm.
Asta trebuie să facem. Și cu cât aveți
mai multe partide de pescuit, cu cât
aveți mai multe informații despre
pescuit, cu atât o să puteți să faceți o
strategie mai bună de fiecare dată când
mergeți. Haideți să vă zic, noi în
fiecare an facem câte o partidă de
pescuit pe mal împreună cu băieții.
Suntem șapte, opt pescari de în funcție
de an, câteodată suntem opt, câteodată
suntem șase și
de doi ani, de trei ani am pescuit pe
brațul sulina și am avut rezultate în
fiecare an. o frecvență foarte bună,
trăsături foarte bune și am fost în
diferite perioade ale verii. Am fost
în iunie,
am fost iunie sau iulie am fost în
iulie, în august n am fost până acum.
Asta e prima oară în care venim în
august pe
pe Sulina și în celelalte în celelalte
partide cotele erau ok, erau în creștere
sau erau stabile și am avut rezultate,
am prins pește și am făcut același lucru
pe care l am făcut și în cu partidele în
partidele anterioare, ba chiar una
dintre partide am făcut o tot aici la
locația asta și am avut trăsături, am
avut frecvență foarte bună. Da, deci cam
asta se întâmplă. Asta se întâmplă dacă
nu avem condițiile ăă atmosferice,
condițiile bune de pescuit, nu o să
prindem pește. Și asta vreau să vă fac
să înțelegeți că peștele, mai ales pe
sălbatic este greu de prins. Și este
greu de prins pentru că nu știm unde să
l căutăm, nu știm ce să facem.
Mai ales că mulți dintre voi pescuiți de
pe mal. De pe mal șansele scad
considerabil. Cum suntem noi acum pe
mal, noi putem să pescuim mai mult pe
apă de 3 m. Am încercat și pe apă de 12
m, dar se rup încontinuu firele și nu
putem să pescuim acolo. Și na, asta e.
Stăm și ne uităm la ele până când mai
intră câte un ciortan, mai avem noroc,
mai vine la lansete, mai stă pe patul de
nad.
Bun, acum haideți să vă mai să vă mai
dau așa un feedback un pic despre
înaintașul de înaintașul de mono de 0,70
destinat pescuitele la somn. Sunt foarte
mulțumit. Deci sunt foarte mulțumit de
acest de acest înaintaș. Nu este
neapărat de firmă, ci este vorba de
grosimea lui că nu se mai taie în
pietre. în pietre și în scoici. Am rupt
firele, dar am rupt firele pentru că mi
s a agățat plumbul sau cârligul într o
piatră și atunci s a rupt de la de la
înainta și de unde a făcut nodul nodul
cu firul principal. Dar înaintașul, să
scot înaintașul tăiat nu mi s a
întâmplat. Da, asta înseamnă că
înaintașul funcționează foarte bine și
în condiții, de exemplu, dacă am pescuit
din barcă, cum a avut Mihai Manea o
partidă din barcă, era ancorat pe apă de
4 m și pescuia pe 12 m. Dacă el atunci
punea un înaintaș de 15 m de mono de 07
08, sunt sigur că nu avea atât de multe
tăieri în scoică și în praguri și reușea
să scoată peștii. Pe lângă asta, este
foarte, foarte important
să pescuim cu plumbi pierduți. Deci eu
peștii pe care i am scos de la adâncime
i am scos datorită înaintașului prima
dată și a faptului și a plumbului
pierdut pentru că el s a pierdut. Deci
eu am scos peștii de la adâncime fără
plumb. Ok. Și o să vă arăt un pic cum
arată ac.
Vedeți că eu acuma fac film cu
telefonul. Deci sistemul arată în genul
ăsta. Da. Și vi le recomand pe acestea
de la FL. Mai am unele de la Carp
Spirit. Carp Spirit? Da. Ăă, nu car
spirit, mă, extract carp. Nu știu ce
firme e asta așa. Ăă, astea vi le
recomand. De ce? Pentru că ele
eliberează foarte ușor plumbul. Deci
dacă plumbul este prins într o piatră,
se eliberează foarte ușor. În schimb,
celelalte nu eliberează plumbul. Mi s a
întâmplat să pescuiesc cu acelea și să
efectiv să se blocheze plumbul în piatră
și nu am reușit să l scot. Normal,
atunci când noi dăm un șoc în lansetă
sau când peștele trage trage cu putere,
datorită acestui sistem, plumbul trebuie
să rămână pe substrat.
și să rămână, mă rog, sistemul sistemul
rămâne, da, dar se pierde se pierde doar
plumbul, de asta și zice plumb pierdut.
Așa că dacă vreți să luați să încercați
montura cu plumb pierdut, vă recomand
acestea de la FL. Na, eu le am folosit
din greșeală, că asta am găsit la
magazin. Nu zic neapărat că astea ar fi
cele mai bune, că sunt convins că sunt
și altele, dar trebuie să fiți atenți ca
să elibereze plumbul în momentul în care
el este agățat. Deci, până acum
combinația asta mie mi se pare perfectă.
împitul în agățătură și în pescuitul în
pietre. Ă un fir
mono de 0,70 destinat pescuitului la
somn sau na, nu neapărat, dar nu știu
dacă există pentru scrap atât de atât de
groase cu plumb pierdut. Și un lucru pe
care vreau să l mai testez, nu l am
testat încă este să folosesc plumi în
formă de lacrimă pentru pescuitul în
pietre. Fiind în formă de lacrimă, mă
gândesc că se agață în pietre mai puțin
decât plumbii clasici.
N am pe aici pe lângă mine să vă arăt
plumbii aceia clasici rotund ba cu gaură
în ei sau fără gaură. Da. Ăia fiind
fiind mai laț agață mai repede în pietre
decât plumbii în formă de lacrimă. Iar
în următoarea partidă o să testez și cu
plumbii în formă de lacrimă sau puteți
să testați și voi cu plumbi în formă de
lacrimă. Mie mi s a părut combinația
asta foarte bună. Am reușit să scot Am
reușit să scot pești
datorită acestui acestei monturi și
încerc în continuare. Acuma mai este o
chestie pe care pe care o fac.
Trebuie să aștept
trăsătura. Deci dacă ieri am avut trei
lansete aruncate pe apă de 10 m, nu
chiar 12 m, că m am zis, uite, după ce m
am uitat cu sonarul, mi am dat seama că
nu prind apa de 12 m.
Din trei lansete am scos doar una.
întreagă. În rest, în rest s au s a s a
tăiat firul, adică s a agățat în în prag
și s a tăiat firul. Deci noi trebuie să
așteptăm trăsătura. Când peștele vine și
trage, îți trage
avem trăsătură, el practic ridică firul,
ridică firul din pietre și l duce în îl
duce în șenal. Deci toate trăsăturile,
cel puțin ce am văzut eu pe Dunăre și pe
pe Sulină, majoritatea peștilor după ce
s au simțit pericol s au înțepat, ei se
duc spre șenal, spre adâncime. Deci aia
este zona lor de protecție. Da? Asta
înseamnă că dacă mie îmi pleacă de aici
din prag, îmi ia îmi ridică îmi ridică
montura împreună cu firul și mi l mi le
duce spre șenal și atunci practic mi le
ridică din pietre. Dar în schimb, dacă
eu trag spre mine de pe mal, eu iau
toate pietrele alea la rând până când
ajung să ridic plumbul de pe substrat ca
lumea ca să ca să l trag să l trag la
suprafață și atunci se pierd se pierd
se pierd monturile și se taie firul sau
se agață și trebuie să rupem. Bun. Cum
pescuim
la adâncimea asta? Adică ce moment
folosim? Ă, eu acum folosesc Delta
Secret pentru că este o bilă tare care
rezistă mai mult la cârlig. Dacă aș
folosi o bilă solubilă aș fi nevoit să
schimb la o oră, poate că o oră și
jumătate și n aș putea să aștept mult pe
trăsătură. Și atunci am pus bilele tari
Delta Secret ca să pot să stau cu ele
patru ore, cinci ore în apă până când
îmi vine trăsătura. Dacă nu mi vine
trăsătura în patru, cinci ore, asta e.
Este o lansetă de sacrificiu.
Am Nu știu, mi am asumat că s ar putea
să rup mult, dar am zis că vreau să arăt
la cameră câțiva pești
ca să, na, că am venit la pește și am
zis că trebuie să prinde și câțiva
pești. Deci cam asta e treaba. Trebuie
să pescuiți cu niște biletari. Delta
Secret sunt perfecte pentru pentru
stilul ăsta de pescuit. Iar Delta Secret
sunt
create de Mihai Manea pentru pescuitul
la pește mare. Așa că dacă trece pește
mare pe acolo, o să prindeți și pește
mare. Cam asta este cu pescuitul, cu
partida noastră de pescuit de până acum.
Astea sunt lucrurile pe care le am
testat și descoperit în această partidă.
Când am ieșit cu sonarul, am văzut am
văzut că erau pești care stăteau pe
prag. Deci pe apa de 3 m nu stăteau, dar
stăteau pe prag pe apă de 7 8 10 12 m.
Da, mă rog, coborau pe prag, ieșeau din
prag. Am văzut câțiva pești pe acolo.
Deci e clar că sunt acolo. Ce am mai
făcut acum diferit a fost să nădesc și
pragul.
Până acum n am nădit pragul. De pe mal
nu pot să notez pragul pentru că este la
distanță
destul de mare comparativ cu cât pot eu
să arunc cu mâna. Și n am luat nicio
paletă la mine ca să pot să arunc mai
departe și atunci nu am cum să nădesc
pragul de pe mal. Am ieșit cu barca și l
am nădit, l am nădit din barcă. I am dat
în jur de 5 kg de bile pe prag.
Nădirea am făcut o la fel. Am dat am dat
mai în monte și ca bilele să cadă pe
zona unde eu pescuiesc. Ok.
Bun. Un alt lucru pe care vreau să vi l
spun eu acuma tot îmi aduc aminte
lucruri și vi le vi le dau ca și
informații. Poate că le știți, poate că
nu le știți, poate că le știți într un
alt fel și această informație ar putea
să vă ajute să completați informația
voastră.
Atunci când lansați,
trebuie să trebuie să sondați înainte
sau să intrați cu barca, să vă uitați cu
sonorul ca să știți unde este pragul.
Nu lansați foarte departe de prag. Dacă
pragul vostru este la 10 m, baza
pragului este la 10 m de voi, voi
încerca să lansați la 12, 13, 14, maxim
15 m. Deci, nu foarte departe. Cu cât
lansez mai departe, cu atât plumbul tău
este purtat pe scenal și este dus mult
la vale. Da. Până se blochează în prag.
Deci noi trebuie să dăm în fața pragului
cu câțiva metri ca el să se blocheze
imediat în prag. Dacă noi dăm mai
departe
există riscul ca atunci când el merge pe
merge pe șenal. Stați un pic de ciocargă
și nu știu dacă mă auziți bine.
Deci atunci când atunci când noi lansăm
departe
plumbul este purtat pe șenal și în tot
acest timp firul nostru, deci firul
nostru este este cum să zic eu târșit,
este tras pe prag. În cazul meu, prag de
piatră, în cazul vostru, nu știu, poate
prag de pământ, poate prag de scoici și
riscăm să se agațe acolo. Am văzut asta
la colegii mei care sunt că da, au dat
departe, departe, aproape la mijlocul
brațului. E normal să se agațe. E normal
să se agațe. Adică cumva trebuie să dai
aproape de prag, aproape de terminarea
pragului și el imediat plumbul tău
imediat să intre în prag. Să nu se să nu
ți se ducă firul prea mult în partea
stângă sau în partea dreaptă. Depinde
cum curge cum curge dunerea. Da.
Dacă pescuiți cu patru lansete, prima și
prima dată dați lanseta din dreapta. Am
mai zis asta pe
clipul pe care l am făcut cu Mihai Manea
pe Chilia. Dacă pescuți cu patru
lansete, când lansați, ar trebui când
schimbați și relansați ar trebui să le
faceți pe toate patru o dată. De ce?
Pentru că începi cu lanseta din partea
dreaptă. Îți iei ia să vă arăt cum am eu
malul.
Da? Deci aici am malul meu, aici sunt
lansetele mele. Să zicem că eu sunt aici
și vreau să lansez și lansez prima
lansetă din partea dreaptă. Ok, îmi iau
ca și reper pomul acesta. Ok, îmi iau ca
și reper pomul acesta. Am lansat, aștept
să să ajungă jos. Ăă aice iar câte o
chestie am văzut am văzut greșeala asta
la unul din pescarii care este cu noi.
lansează și imediat a dat pick up ul și
atunci practic nu și mai a
nu se mai
derulează fir de pe de pe tambur, ci
efectiv este blocat este blocat firul pe
tambur și toată montura noastră, plumbul
nostru în loc să se ducă așa la vale,
da, el vine spre noi așa pentru că taie
cumva apa. Ok, noi luăm, deci după ce am
făcut lansarea, plumbul a atins apa, noi
ținem ușor cu mâna de de fir, nu i dăm
drumul la fir ca să se ia mult fir, să
ia mult fir în curent și ținem un pic
semibloat până simțim că a atins fundul.
Când am simțit că a atins fundul, atunci
dăm pick up ul și ținem lanseta în mână
până când ea până când noi simțim că
plumbul nu se mai mișcă. Da? Până când
ea până când plumbul se fixează în prag.
Ok. Așa. Deci facem lansarea. Da. Ne am
luat reper acest copac și lansăm prim
lanseta din partea dreaptă. Facem
lansarea către el. Așteptăm să pice
plumbul, punem punem lanseta pe suport.
După care a doua lansetă ne luăm reper,
să zicem, pietrele astea de aici, da?
Sau to fast. Deci nu dăm tot aici pentru
că o să dăm peste lanseta asta. Curentul
e la fel. Noi pescuim cu aceleași cu
aceleași greutăți. Da, dacă am luat și
am aruncat aici, o să cadă frumos și o
să se alinieze foarte frumos lângă prima
lansetă și tot așa. A doua, a treia
lansetă aici, a patra lansetă aici și
toate sunt aliniate. Da? Și asta ne va
ajuta dacă ne luăm un reper pe partea
aia opusă pe fiecare lansetă ne va ajuta
dacă avem un drip pe o lansetă. Nu le
mai scoatem pe toate patru ca să le să
le aruncăm din nou să le să le cum să
zic eu să le deranjăm frumos. Efectiv
dacă eu știu că am scos prima lansetă,
îmi știu că am reperul pe copacul ăsta
și arunc pe copacul ăsta și va cădea tot
în zona respectivă. Da, nu fix, dar va
cădea tot în zona respectivă. Ok, deci
asta este o altă informație. Ăsta este
un alt lucru pe care vi l spun cum să
cum să l lansați și zic asta pentru că
mă uit la pescarela cu care sunt și mai
văd diferite greșeli și mie mi se par
cum să zic eu mi se par niște lucruri le
am făcut de atât de multe ori și mi se
par că sunt niște lucruri care sunt de
la sine înțelesși și încă n ar trebui să
le explic dar trebuie explicate pentru
că mă uit la pescarii care sunt și am
văzut că nu nu le fac.
Cam atât momentan așteptăm să vedem dacă
ne mai intră ceva shortortan. Dacă nu am
avut triluri, am avut trăsături. Să vă
fac un mic update. De când am terminat
de filmat
acum 30 de minute, Costin a scos și el
un crap de 3 kg, iar Cristi a avut a
avut o trăsătură, a avut un pește mai
mare, l a înțepat. S a văzut pe lansetă,
era un pește mai mare, dar a scăpat.
Aici mai vreau să vă zic ceva. Cristi un
pescar începător. Pescuiește de doi ani
de zile și nici nu prea ascultă,
nu prea vrea să asculte. Ieri mi a
arătat un lig sau am văzut la el un cu
două bile de 24
și un cârlig de opt de feeder
și i am zis: "Cristi, dacă ție îți vine
un pește, nu vei putea să l înțepi
pentru că nu ai mecanica potrivită la
cârlig. Nu se va înțepa. Iar acum mai
devreme a scăpat un pește și sunt curios
dacă avea rigul ăla sau sunt curios să i
văd rigul.
[Muzică]
Am mai avut două trăsături, de fapt
trei, nu două trăsături. Un run de pe
apă de 3 m pe patul de nadă, pe care tot
l am alimentat și am avut un run super
puternic. A luat fir ca lumea. L am
ținut, l am ținut. N am reușit să l țin
prea bine. A intrat în tirul altei
lansete și și a dat drumul
mă rog, a scăpat cârligul și am mai avut
un pește de pe
apa de 10 m, 12 m.
[Muzică]
Am ajuns pe seară. Este ora 5:00 și
ceva.
Astăzi am avut 15 scoși. Au mai fost și
câteva rateuri.
Pe apa de 10 m, 12 m. Am avut o singură
trăsătură.
Iar pe apa de 3 m am avut mai multe
trăsături și am observat că și cu
colegii mei pescari au început să aibă
trăsături pe apă de 3 m. Asta este bine.
Înseamnă că peștele
s a obișnuit un pic cu bilele pe care
noi le am tot și vine să le consume. Nu
am slăbit absolut deloc patul de nadă. I
am dat încontinuu bile din, hai să zic
că nu chiar din oră în oră. câteodată,
na, am fost la masă, am mai stat un pic
în foișor și poate că n am dat de
fiecare dată din oră în oră, dar am dat
constant bile. Atunci când am lăsat o
perioadă mai lungă de timp fără să nim
fără să dăm bile, am dat mai multe bile
și tot așa.
Momentan sunt mulțumit față de de marți
când am ajuns și având în vedere cota
care este super scăzută și presiunea
care a scăzut și ea, faptul că am avut
câteva trăsături este perfect, că am
avut și prezentări
este chiar este chiar din punctul meu de
vedere foarte bine. Acum să vedem
colegii mei pescari sunt hotărâți să
pescuiască și pe noapte. În continuare
alimentăm vadurile, dăm bile în
continuare. Sunt ei sunt vor pescui și
pe noapte. Cred că o să stau și eu cu ei
până pe la 1:00 și mai avem și mâine o
zi de pescuit, după care sâmbătă plecăm.
Sunt sigur că o să mai avem ceva
trăsături. Să vedem dacă crește
frecvența. Deci astăzi, până la ora asta
eu am scos cinci pești, am mai avut
câteva trăsuturi și ratate,
iar mâine vreau să văd tot la ora asta
câți câți pești am scoși. În continuare
înaintașul este ok de 0,70. V am zis că
asta testez în partida asta. I am dat și
lui Costin înaintaș pentru că și el a
rupt. A avut multe a avut și el multe
rupturi. Să vedem și la el cum cum se
comportă. Și na, cam asta este. Neața,
dragi pescari. N am rezistat să nu ies
cu barca pe apă. Am zis că dacă tot am
cinci zile de pescuit, mi ar părea rău
să știu că sunt pe Dunăre și să nu ies
cu barca să caut niște locuri mai bune.
Așa că am ieșit dimineață, sunt împreună
cu Marius și vom pescui toată ziua pe
Sulina. După mi la 8:00 am găsit un loc,
ne am băgat într o salcie, am gătit un
pic și așteptăm așteptăm să vedem ce
rezultate avem. Ieri s au mai prins
câțiva ciortani.
A început și
vadul unde l am nădit încontinuu. A
început și el să dea pește. Într adevăr,
peștii erau mai micuți, 1 kg 1,g. Cred
că cel mai mare avea 2 kg.
Lansetele de pe adâncime ieri mi au dat
un singur pește și cam asta a fost.
Astăzi suntem
pe braț pe sulina. Am ieșit cu barca și
așteptăm să vedem poate reușim să
scoatem ceva mai mare, să vă arătăm și
vouă la cameră. Dacă nu, o să mergem la
cazare. Mâine, Astăzi este ultima zi,
mâine o luăm spre casă.
Dă încoace.
Și ți am zis,
mă.
>> Serios?
[Muzică]
Mai are
Aici ce rujati. Vezi? Hm. Ăsta stă și
mănâncă scoică de drag. Uite le.
Zile de 24
Delta Secret.
Până la ora 2:30 n am avut nicio
trăsătură.
La 2:30 am avut un run. S a lăsat pe ea.
A plecat foarte puternic.
Am avut un drill de, să zic 3 minute,
după care s a dezgățat.
Era un pește mai mare, după care am mai
avut un ciortan și acuma a mai venit un
pește.
Stăm până diseară, vedem ce o să iasă.
Poate reușim să scoatem și ceva mai
mare, să arătăm la cameră.
[Muzică]
O, Marius! Ia uite l, Marius!
>> Da, da, da. Ai grijă acolo. Dacă vin pe
partea asta.
>> Ia uite l
frumos.
Ou!
>> Bine!
>> Bravo, Gabi!
>> Bravo, Marius!
Marius a zis așa: "Cred că toate bilele
noastre s au dus mult la vale și de
acolo o să vină peștele". Și a avut
dreptate. Ia uitați. Ia uitați ce avem
aici. Ia filmează.
Ia uitați, mă, băieți.
Și minciogul e mare. Da. Uitați și bila
Delta Secret. Uite o cum.
Da.
Hai să i facem poze și să l eliberăm.
Dragi pescari, am riscat și a venit
acest superb crab de 7 kg la bilele
Delta Secret. Am mai avut și un alt
ciortan în afară de ăsta.
O să l eliberăm imediat. Oprim filmarea
și o să vă pun și filmarea cu
eliberarea. Urmează
eliberarea
și neć
I
superb, superb.
>> Bravo!
Neața, dragi pescari! Este gata partida
noastră de pescuit. S a terminat bine, s
a terminat de aseară pentru că nu eu nu
am mai pescuit. Băieții au mai pescuit
de pe mal. A fost o partidă reușită din
punctul meu de vedere, având în vedere
condițiile. Cota a fost scăzută,
presiunea a fost scăzută. Cel puțin ieri
presiunea a scăzut brusc, cotele sunt
scăzute în luna august și noi am reușit
să prindem totuși pește. Prietenii mei
de pe mal ieri au avut o super partidă.
au prins în jur de
12 pești între 2 kg și 3 kg, nu mai mari
de atât. Eu am ieșit cu barca, am prins
un crap de 7 kg de pe barcă și am mai
avut trei rupturi plus încă un crap la 3
kg 3,5 și un ciortan. Cam asta a fost
partida noastră. Ne am adaptat, am nădit
constant, așa cum v am spus,
am alimentat vadurile,
cel puțin aici de pe mal, băieții au
au nădit constant. Și eu am nădit timp
de patru zile.
Ieri nu am mai nădit pentru că am ieșit
cu barca și nu avea sens să mai nădesc,
dar băieții au nădit în continuare și
peștii până la urmă s au instalat pe
vad. Chiar dacă
a fost scăzută presiunea și a fost
scăzută și cota, am reușit să scoatem
câțiva ciortani. Știți, vă spuneam la
începutul clipului că o partidă de
pescuit poate să fie reușită sau poate
să fie nereușită.
Reușita unei partide de pescuit stă
foarte mult în experiența pescarului,
înțiile pe care le are și cât de repede
se adaptează la condițiile din partida
lui. Asta am făcut și noi. Ne am
adaptat. Am încercat să găsim cea mai
bună soluție pentru condițiile noastre
și am reușit să scoatem câțiva crapi. Ce
vreau să vă transmit în final este
ideea asta în care
încerc să încerc să vă încerc să vă
conving cumva că nu nadele și momeliile
sunt cele care vă aduc peștele la poze,
ci experiența voastră ca și pescari. ăă
nadele și momelile este necesar să fie
niște nade bune, niște nade actualizate
pentru pescuitul pe sălbatic.
Mecanica să fie corectă,
să vă ajute să reziste pe substrat sau
în funcție de ce faceți, în funcție de
pescuitul pe care pe care l practicați,
am clienți care mă sună și mi spun: „Dă
mi și mie ceva sau fă mi pe un buget de
1000 RON fă mi un pachet pentru Dunăre
și prima dată îl întreb" Ce pescuiești
pe Dunăre? Ce vrei să faci pe Dunăre?
Unde pescuiești pe Dunăre?
În ce anotimp vrei să te duci pe Dunăre?
Că dacă vrei să vii acum în august îți
dau un pachet. Dacă vrei să te duci în
octombrie, ai un alt pachet. Adică
trebuie să adaptezi nadele și momeliile
în funcție de temperatura apei, de
anotim și bineînțeles de peștele pe care
î vizezi. Dacă vizezi pește pești mici
hai să zicem nu neapărat mici, ciortani,
pești crapi până în 3 4 kg, atunci poți
să pescuiești liniștit cu momitoare,
poți să faci o nădire cu bile și să
pescuieș cu momitoare. Asta în perioada
de vară. Dacă vrei să pescuiești la
pește mare, atunci trebuie să faci o
nădire corectă.
și foarte abundentă cu bile Delta
Secret, cu bile Fish Meal, cu bile tari
și neapărat să pescuiești pe adâncime.
În partida de ieri eu am pescuit pe
adâncime. Am mers pe locul de pescuită
unde prietenul meu a prins foarte foarte
bine. Dacă cred că v am mai spus, a avut
o super partidă. Ieri a plecat și el din
deltă și a prins
mulți crapi. Într o zi mi a spus că a
avut peste 20 de crapi, unul fiind de 18
kg, unul de 15 și mulți de 7, de 8 și de
10.
Și de asta și eu m am m am mobilizat și
am zis hai să ies și eu cu barca pentru
că am zis că peștele la adâncime, dar
ieri ce s a întâmplat? A scăzut a
presiunea foarte brusc.
Nici nici prietenul meu nu a mai avut
super capturi. A avut câteva capturi,
dar n a avut atât de multe. A avut
precum am avut și noi, câteva trăsături
toată ziua, dar a fost ok pentru că am
reușit să scoatem un crap de 7 kg și eu
mă declar foarte foarte mulțumit pentru
condițiile în care ne aflăm. Ce să vă
zic? Vă mulțumesc frumos că ați stat
până la final, că ați urmărit până la
final. Sper că v ați luat valoare din
din acest clip. Am încercat să explic
cât de cât din experiența mea și vor
urma și alte clipuri pe care o să le fac
singur sau împreună cu Mihai Manea, care
este un pescar foarte bun de Delta
Dunării și o să încercăm să explicăm mai
multe lucruri, mai multe tehnici pe care
le folosim,
echipamentul pe care î folosim și așa
mai departe. Vă mulțumesc încă o dată că
ați fost alături de mine și nu uitați să
lăsați un share, un like și un
comentariu dacă aveți o întrebare de la
mine. Vă salut și vă doresc fi întins.
>> Băieți,
[Râsete]
>> da.
Băieți, în drum spre Tulcea.
Băga mi aș
>> băieții. Gata, mă.